Welcome back everyone is Charlie this is going
to be my new spider-man 3 movie video there was
a lot of live-action spider-verse stuff happening
the past couple of days there was even a teaser
video that posted to an official sony youtube
channel that i'll talk about during the video
i've also got some animated spider-man into
the spider-verse 2 stuff that i'll add to the
end of the video too so if you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe to get all the
videos there's going to be a bunch of marvel
stuff happening in the next couple of months
especially with avengers wandavision episodes
starting they'll be filming spider-man 3 for a
while it's still supposed to come out december
2021 next year but number 5 if you didn't see
the news the past few days both jimmy kimmel
and a separate sony channel were releasing
new spider-man 3 spider-verse content i
can only play some of the clips in the
video because some of it's getting taken down in
different places but this is the kimmel clip of
him talking to zendaya about tobey maguire and
andrew garfield on set being in the spider-man
3 movie where are you you're in atlanta
right now shooting uh spider-man 3 correct
correct correct you can say that i know every
it's very secretive right yes everything is very
secretive is it called spider-man 3 because there
are three spider-men in the movie i can neither
confirm nor tonight you cannot get oh interesting
did you have did you have thanksgiving there in
atlanta yes we did we had a a bubble
thanksgiving with spider-man yeah i can't say
that was good that was good that's good yeah
because i was wondering what you guys have
because i know Tobey maguire is a vegan and i was
wondering if he had like a tofurkey or something
i have no idea you have no idea really i
really don't i really don't hey everyone oh
sorry i'm late it's a jungle out there i had to
beat an old lady with a stick to get these cramps
so you watched that clip and by itself
it seems like he's just messing with her
but because he's talking about tobey maguire and
andrew garfield so much being in spider-man 3 it
almost sounds like soft confirmation that there'll
be some kind of spider-verse easter eggs of some
sort in the movie whether or not we actually see
Tobey maguire or andrew garfield appear on screen
like he wouldn't bother to make jokes about it
if it weren't at least a little bit true he'd be
joking about some other aspect of spider-man there
were a lot of clips of andrew garfield filming
outdoors in new york city when they were filming
spider-man 3 stuff but he was actually filming for
a different movie so just because he was being
filmed around that same time doesn't mean that
that was for spider-man 3 necessarily number 4
the other spider-man 3 trailer video you guys
were asking me about in the past few days was a
video that was posted to the official sony latino
american youtube channel then quickly deleted
the video was titled all three spider-man and i
was able to watch it before it was taken down and
translate what was being said but yesterday some
other youtubers were saying that sony themselves
were going around taking the trailer reactions
down from their channels so i can't just play
the entire clip in this video that's like the
worst thing that could happen to a youtube video
taking it down with a copyright claim for example
normally when sony claims other people's videos
for using spiderman movie footage or other movie
footage they either claim the revenue from the
video themselves but typically leave the video
up so the fact that they wanted the video gone
completely from youtube seemed kind of suspicious
but this is what the video said so it starts with
who's your favorite spider-man and then it goes
through a montage of the different spider-man
movies with tobey maguire andrew garfield and
tom holland spider-man then it says you don't have
to choose in the marvel multiverse everything can
happen and in spider-man 3 quite possibly you will
see everyone the three peter parkers saving the
world together find out more soon on o-n and o-n
is just the sony-owned news brand in latin america
that's uploading these videos so what i think
is going on here is that the sony news channel
just made this video because of all the
spider-man 3 Tobey mcguire andrew garfield
cameo scene rumors that have been happening the
last couple of months and it's just meant to be
a newsy hype video like hey this is a thing that
might actually end up happening and they're not
trying to say yes it's definitely happening or
it's confirmed now more like a hype video that
you would see on a normal youtube channel meant
to also promote their sony news channel like j
jonah jameson would make a youtube video for
the dailybugle.net there was even a video they
released after spider-man far from home in his big
cameo seen in the post credits rated the classic
youtube poll of please like and subscribe that's
probably one of my favorite promos that they've
ever released for the spider-man movies you are
a criminal a miscreant a masked marauder a menace
thanks for watching don't forget to like and
subscribe so yes it's totally possible that
this sony latin american channel knows something
that we don't know because it is owned by sony
so all these people are being paid by sony but i
think the real reason why the bigger sony people
are taking this video down not only from their
own channel but from other people's channels
isn't so much because they're worried about
spoilers or anything is that they're more
concerned that people will see this video
and think that it's confirmation that they
are doing full-blown live-action spider-verse
in spider-man 3. when really what's probably
going on it was just a couple of news editors
who decided to make a fun speculation theory
video that's only a minute long like the video
itself is only a minute it's super short video
but because it's coming from an official sony
channel people tend to think that it's official
confirmation of something whether or not their
employees just went rogue in this one scenario
sony probably just doesn't want people thinking
that it's an official spider-man 3 trailer
the fact that jimmy kimmel was doing all his
spider-man 3 spider-verse jokes within a day
or two of this happening the timing seemed kind
of suspect yes but like i said even if tobey
maguire and andrew garfield themselves don't
appear in the movie i still think that they're
going to reference the real multiverse or spider
verse since we're talking about spider-man movies
if you're not a big comic book fan technically
the spider-verse is sort of a different layer
of reality from the multiverse you call it the web
of life and destiny but effectively kind of works
out to the same thing they travel the multiverse
in slightly different ways than people like the
avengers did during avengers end game if you're
a big fan of this stuff and you want some super
deep cuts and you haven't watched it already they
have the 90s animated spider-man cartoon series
on disney plus and they get into a lot of the
spider verse with madame webb during that series
you also have to think about how marvel has been
setting up the idea of the multiverse already
starting with the first doctor strange movie then
during avengers end game the ancient one tells the
hulk about the alternate timelines created with
the infinity stones then during spider-man far
from home mysterio lies about where he comes
from but even kevin feige confirmed he was not
lying about the existence of the multiverse this
is a clip of him talking about that at comic con
just because quentin beck makes up lies about
the multiverse doesn't mean it isn't real dr
strange in the multiverse of madness so kevin
feige wouldn't have doubled down on that in
an official marvel panel if he weren't planning
on continuing that theme of the multiverse with
future spider-man stories in taboo this was during
the doctor strange 2 multiverse of madness panel
we just got confirmation a little while ago
that doctor strange was going to be a major
avengers crossover character in spider-man 3. so
they're using doctor strange 2 and that character
to continue this spider-man moment from spider-man
far from home talking about the multiverse so it's
pretty safe to assume there'll be some kind
of multiverse easter eggs or elements during
spider-man 3. and it's even in the title of doctor
strange 2 that's going to be the most over-the-top
crazy version of a multiverse story in the mcu
because it's literally called multiverse of
madness spider-man 3 is coming out before that in
every marvel phase 4 movie is going to have some
kind of multiverse theme story crossover elements
it all starts with the Wandavision episodes in
january with scarlet witch messing with reality
in the multiverse in a way that just leads to
bigger consequences and problems later on that
forced doctor strange to get involved they've
already confirmed that the Wandavision episodes
are directly setting up doctor strange 2 but
the consequences of what scarlet witch does during
that series will be felt in ripples across all the
marvel phase 4 movies to different degrees there's
a lot of different stuff that they're setting up
with the early marvel phase 4 movies and series
some of it's multiverse some of its mutants and
x-men characters and some of it's the next big
avengers team at avengers 5 young avengers as well
so as we get more information more details and we
start seeing those movies hopefully we'll actually
get to see these movies at some point i'll do new
easter egg videos just based on these different
things and speaking of spider-verse there was
a new spider-man into the spider-verse 2 movie
video that i did with a bunch of easter eggs last
week that i think a couple people were confused by
because they're doing some spider-verse crossover
stuff with a mobile game in the near future
and in a lot of the bonus spider-verse content
there was a bunch of x-men stuff happening so
just to be clear this is just bonus spider-verse
content with the characters from the movies but
characters like mojo for instance aren't going to
show up during spider-man into the spider-verse 2.
like a bunch of x-men characters in ultron aren't
suddenly going to show up out of nowhere they
did a lot of ridiculous promos like this when the
first spider-verse movie came out with spider-ham
with a bunch of bonus content featuring his
character and other characters that did not
appear during the actual movie so shout out to my
man ilac skills who let me know about the video
game stuff that they're doing right now but they
will be filming spider-man 3 for a good long while
so if you have any special bonus video requests
for spider-man 3 or any of the other spider-man
movies like venom 2 or morbius let me know in
the comments there was a new morbius trailer
video that dropped a little while ago so i might
do a video for that in the next couple of days
obviously there's a bunch of mandalorian season
2 stuff happening so as long as you have alerts
enabled for my channel you should see all those
videos when they post everyone click here for my
brand new mandalorian season 2 episode 6 video
and click here for my new spider-man 3 andrew
garfield video thank you so much for watching
everyone stay safe i'll see you guys tonight!